[MUSIC PLAYING]
NORMAN WOODARD: Thank you
very much for attending
this session.
So today we'll be talking about
rearchitecting apps for cloud,
the why, how, and so what.
Let me introduce myself.
My name is Norman Woodard.
I am with Accenture.
And I am a global
apigee practice lead.
I also am part of our Accenture
Google business group.
And so my play, as we
call it within that
as far as an offering
within that group
is actually dedicated to what we
call next gen app development.
This is entirely focused
on microservices, APIs,
and containerization.
App monetization,
rearchitecting for cloud
is what we do day
in and day out.
So excited to be here today.
Let's get started.
So we're seeing a paradox.
Recently Accenture did a survey
of lots of different CXOs
in different organizations.
And basically what
we found was that you
know there's legacy debt
that's inside of our platforms
inside of the
infrastructure that comprise
a lot of the operating systems
and basically your business
as you're doing it
today within IT.
So what does this mean?
Well, the good part
is you've got data.
And there's lots of
valuable information
that's useful to serve
customers, generate
revenue, drive new
business and innovation.
However, the bad part is, and
therefore the paradox, not able
to get access to that data.
So as much as, for example,
70% of C-suite executives
that we talked to said
that trapped data that's
inside those monolithic
applications typically
is what's severely limiting
IT's ability to innovate.
In other words, it's
keeping them back
from being able to move forward.
So they can't innovate.
They can't adopt new platforms.
They're challenged to be able to
look at new innovative products
and technologies
in the marketplace.
So this is really hamstringing
the ability for IT
to keep up with the
pace of business.
So what does this mean?
Well, part of it is
that that legacy debt
is holding them back.
Yes, we've talked
about that already.
But what it also means,
and more importantly,
is the business is not
able to innovate at speed.
So what that also starts
to create as a lot of us
see is fragmentation.
So a business may start trying
to do things on their own,
try to deviate from IT.
And so you started getting lots
of discontinuity in services,
being able to maintain
those services, and also
operator scale those.
So technical debt,
as we see it, is
what I was just
defining, the locked
in investments, in
platforms, technology,
development inside those
monolithic applications.
That's creating not one, a
higher risk of discontinuity.
So in other words,
more of your systems
are going to be apt to break
that cause outages, cause
service disruptions, therefore
impeding your ability
to service not only your
enterprise but also your client
base as well.
You also have
increased complexity.
So lots of time and investment
into those applications.
Lots of data, of course,
in there, because that's
where you're housing
all of your information,
both in your customers, your
products, your services,
and your capabilities.
So what that's also
doing is that's creating
a lock on your data
and on what you're
trying to be able to carry
the business forward on.
So therefore, what that leads
to is reducing IT's ability
to be nimble, be agile.
It also affects
the ability of IT
to be healthy in
respect of being
able to provide new services,
business continuity,
constant uptime, but also create
nimbleness and effectiveness
in being able to move the
services and the capabilities
forward in order to innovate
at the speed at which business
is looking to operate.
So when we talk about
drivers of app monetization,
getting ready to
move to cloud, what
does that whole
aspect look like?
What are we talking about?
So getting ready
to re-architect,
move to either
containerize and be
more nimble inside
of the back office
or move to cloud or
even hybrid cloud
as we see most of our
clients doing today.
So drivers of that app
modernization and cloud
migration is going to
be primarily either kind
of the obvious, right?
So it's either business
driven, so there's
business priorities, either
new innovation or revenue.
There may may be
cost cutting aspects
as well from the business
side or it can be IT driven,
so whether it's infrastructure
led, technology, legacy,
end of life systems or drivers
to consolidate platforms,
licensing costs, other locked
factors as terms of driving up
the IT budget so
cost reduction being
a primal importance and then
also the cost of maintenance,
not just in terms of dollars
but also the resources required
to maintain those platforms
and infrastructure.
So new approach
needs to be taken.
How do you get started?
Where do you-- what is
his journey look like?
So we're trying to
simplify it down,
just three simple aspects.
So first off, let's
start with assess.
Develop a consistent measured
approach to how you're going
to remediate, how are you going
to get ready to re-architect
your apps, re-architect
your infrastructure
and your services and be able
to provide that path towards
elasticity, scalability, and
manageability, essentially--
then use technology.
So the best practice,
as we see it
and what we advise our clients--
and also I don't
mean just advise,
I mean, we implement this for
a lot of clients day in and day
out.
Digital decoupling. new
way of using an old term.
And it's my phrase, so I'll
play with a little bit here.
But-- we've heard
digital decoupling--
I'm sure many of
you have before--
what does this really mean?
So it's separating
out your technology.
It's providing a
abstraction layer that--
you don't start from
scratch approach,
you're laying on top
and with that you're
providing the
infrastructure to be
able to decouple your services
from your backend platforms
and enable the separation
from your apps,
and your systems of record,
and your systems of engagement.
And then next is
going to be evolve,
so now it's a matter of-- as you
start laying that foundation,
you move towards
what technology--
with the decoupling you're going
to move towards a API-centric,
microservices
containers approach
to all of your applications
and your services.
Now, take it to the
next step and that
has evolve to where you're
making it more elastic,
you're making it to where
you can expand your services,
your capabilities.
You've got a framework for
managing, not only security,
but also managing the
services-- have visibility,
not only to performance, but
also to what data is being
passed, how it's being
passed, and being
able to scale those services,
so that your infrastructure is
servicing your applications
and not your applications
being your end customer,
but actually driving
the use of the data to
enable the business.
So how do you start
eliminating and preventing
this technical debt?
Well, the technical
debt starts, typically,
all these investments,
as we're just
talked about a minute ago--
the monolithic application
or applications,
there can be more than
one, so talking about CRM,
product databases, HR,
numbers of different systems,
supply chain, you've got
multiple that are typically
existent in every enterprise.
As we've all
started evolving, we
started with the best
in breed at the time.
Well, those-- have you--
technology's evolved--
it absolutely evolved and
now there's new stuff out--
rate of change that we
all experience today.
But what this also means is now
you need to, as you're looking
to re-architect your
applications and enable more
of a cloud native
ready infrastructure
and your approach
to applications--
now start taking it to where
your decoupling your services
from those monolithic
applications--
break out to those services,
break out that data--
and expose it to where you
can actually access it,
your application developers
are able to incorporate
those services, consume those
into applications far easier,
and, therefore, you're able to
create reasonable assets rather
than constantly creating
the same connection,
the same interface, the
same API, or microservice
to a number of
different applications.
So now you're going towards
developing reusable assets
and then you've got
a basis of where
you can start
creating scalability
and be able to
manage that approach.
So entry points--
where do you start?
Where does this journey begin?
Where do you jump into it?
Every enterprise is
going to be different
and with that every
application is
going to be at a different
stage in its lifecycle.
Your business is going to
have a different entry point.
So where is the business?
I don't mean IT,
so I'm separating
those out for a second.
But IT Is going to
have separate drivers,
so you need to understand
what are the factors that are
driving them to want to move
the application or capability
to cloud in this case, same
thing apply if you're keeping
it on-prem--
principles are
very, very similar.
So is it innovation?
Are they trying to offer new
capabilities, new services?
Are they trying to provide
business continuity?
Are they-- is it
revenue impacting
or is it cost reduction?
What are the business drivers?
That's important
factor to understand.
And then also relate it to it
from the IT side of the house--
is assess the current
state of the application.
Where is it at in its maturity?
Where is it at in its evolution?
Are-- is IT and business
for that matter cloud ready?
Do you have those--
is that support and
infrastructure in place?
And what are the
priority drivers for--
from an IT perspective?
Is a cost reduction?
Is infrastructure consolidation?
Is it application
renewal, refresh?
Just understanding those and
then from there you can start
to begin to figure
out, all right,
using this framework as you're
seeing in front of you--
leveraging the aspect--
the concept of decoupling, where
does it begin to fit together?
So, now, you can pick where
is the appropriate entry point
and you start from there.
So it's usually understanding
these aspects first,
knowing that you're going to go
towards a digital decoupling--
an API, a microservice
containerization approach--
and then there it starts--
OK, so now get into
proof of concept.
Look at your architecture, proof
of concepts on your services,
make sure you don't
forget about security,
and also, from a development--
how the services going
to be accessed and maintained.
So it's important to
have all four aspects
incorporated into some of
those proof of concepts
to validate the
approach, validate
the business goals
are going to be
met with the approach
of the architecture
and the infrastructure.
And then you start on
your way towards going
towards implementation.
All right.
So building blocks.
So look at change data capture,
so look at how data's captured.
See how that's
going to play into
and understand how that's going
to affect your infrastructure
and your applications.
Look at your event-driven
architecture.
How is your-- what
are the events that
are going to be driven?
What are the applications
and platforms?
They're are going to be
driving those events.
What data needs to be captured?
How is it going to be processed?
And what is it also
going to be triggering?
Then you start looking at
microservices and your APIs.
So what's your API and
microservice strategy
with Google?
And what I enjoy working
with very passionately
for the last five years,
definitely Apigee, and then
leveraging Istio and Kubernetes.
Real strong platforms to be able
to springboard off and provide
this infrastructure
on a robust scale.
So this is what we do
a lot with our clients.
And that's ultimately going
to lead to an improved user
experience.
So being able to
deliver faster, but also
improve the user experience to
where they're getting better--
more value out of
those applications,
and driving how they're going
to be able to not only use
the app, but also driving
the adoption of the app
and the services as well.
All right.
So with this, I'm going to
turn it over to my colleague.
And he'll walk you
through the next steps
on how you start this journey,
and what's our approach.
MAMOUN HIRZALLA: Hey,
good morning, everybody.
So my name is Mamoun Hirzalla.
My role with
Accenture is primarily
leading the solution
delivery and architecture
for North America.
And I have been in the industry
for more than 20 years,
primarily building
custom applications
on different architectural
styles for a variety
of customers and industries.
And today, what I'm
going to be going over
is talk about how we can
take the concepts that Norman
mentioned, and distill them
into an approach that's
risk-mitigated, has been worked
out with customers in the past.
And then what are the things
that you need to watch out for,
so that when you go implement
this type of journey,
you are successful and
minimize the amount of risk.
And hopefully your
C-level suite would
be impressed by what you have
done as part of the process.
So let's start talking about
the exponential architecture.
And what does that mean from
taking an existing monolith
or legacy type of
system, and trying
to modernize those
type of systems
and get them into a shape where
I can fulfill my primary two
drivers for building
any type of system,
whether I want to
reduce cost or I
want to increase
agility and innovation.
Right?
So for the past 20
plus years, this
has been the two
drivers that driving
the majority of the projects
that I have worked on.
And this is no different.
So it's always that
question that we
have to answer, on
what type of metrics
that we need to put
upfront to make sure
that we are successful
as part of the process.
And as you can imagine
this is not an easy task.
So in order to get
there safely, you
have to put some
kind of baby steps
in place, so that you
can get to that journey
in a kind of governed
approach, so that you
can scale later down the road.
And if you need to
fail, you fail fast,
as part of agile
type of principles.
And you adjust
based on the results
that you have went
through as part
of the initial steps
of that process.
And that's exactly what this
number one showing here.
You need to start small, right?
And as part of that
process, you need
to define what we call a proof
of architecture, where you can
go through these
type of processes,
and you craft out some use
cases as part of your domain.
You define one or
two use cases that
would touch upon
many of the systems
that you are going to touch.
So there are no
cutting corners here.
The reason we cut corners
got us into technical debt,
and we got into where we are
right now because of that.
So as part of your POA,
you want to address
those hard questions,
in order to make sure
that you don't get
surprises down the road.
So you try to put to use cases.
You try to touch upon many of
the layers of the architecture
that you're building.
And then you execute.
And then you figure out what is
the outcome of that execution.
And what are the things that
went right versus things
that may have not.
And what type of
tweaks, enhancements
that I need to do as
part of the process
so that I can get to the latter
stages of the process, where
I can optimize and
scale and deliver
all of these type of things
with certainty and good results
as part of the process.
So that's really what this
thing is all about here,
to make sure that we get
into these type of steps.
I've seen many clients in the
past where they go and start
hesitating, or
things don't go well
because there are so
many things that they
needed to iron out before going
and doing starting anything.
And we've seen that pattern.
And the way around that
is to define exactly
what type of objectives
that you want to do.
And use those guiding
principles to--
if discussions
happen or conflict
arises, use these
metrics, principles
to guide you
through the process,
and try to make decisions
and move forward.
And this is what I
mentioned as part
of the proof of architecture.
So we select the
business priorities,
what is it that we
want to accomplish.
There are definitely
certain business priorities
that we want to accomplish.
Pick one or two use case.
Start with the high level
architectural blueprint.
If I'm going to
use microservices,
event-driven type
of architecture,
what are the primary components,
what are the primary scenarios?
And then start small in
terms of your DevOps.
I understand that
when you go and look
at DevOps type of articles,
you have these 10, 12
tools that are all integrated
in a nicely mature fashion.
But is that really what you
want initially from the get go?
Most likely not.
I haven't seen one
customer started with that.
So you need to start with
what makes sense for you.
One, two tools to start with.
Doesn't have to be perfect.
You can start with
that, learn the lessons,
add additional
tools, find the gaps,
and incrementally move
over until you kind of get
to that stage where now
I know exactly what I'm
trying to accomplish,
I learned the lessons,
and now I can continue
a cycle of evaluation
and building till you finalize
that state where you get
into the optimization mode,
and building at scale,
and having any factory
or set up that you
want to do down the road.
Now, to talk about
digital decoupling
in terms of more peeling
the layers of onion,
there are twelve steps
that we have seen
with working with customers.
You may merge one
step into the other
or whatever, doesn't matter.
But the process stays
the same, right?
Whether it's 10 or 12, you
have to cover your bases
as part of what's needed, as
part of the digital decoupling.
So starting with the
defining the domains,
trying to understand what
is it that I want to build,
what type of business
problem that I'm trying
to tackle, what type of issues.
All the way down to
decoupling the organization
and reaching out into a
state where things are
running in a smooth fashion.
So let's take step by
step into figuring out
what these things mean,
and how they figure out
into digital decoupling.
So the first thing
I need to understand
is, what are my logical
boundaries, right?
If you're an
airline company, you
have two types of
models potentially.
You have award booking,
non-award booking.
If you're a bank, you may
have commercial banking,
retail banking, right?
And so on.
Every customer knows
their primary domains.
And what am I
trying to focus on?
I'm trying to focus
on A or B. And then
within A or B, what are the
priorities that I want to get?
If I'm having issues
with issuing policies
for my customers, it's taken
an extraordinary amount of time
to do that because
of my monolith,
and then there are certain
rules that nobody knows about--
is there something that
I can do to fix that?
Is that part of
my prioritization,
my scenarios that I want to
tackle as part of the process.
And then trying to understand
the interdependencies.
So you probably, at the
beginning of the stage,
you don't want to pick
something where there are so
many interdependencies on that
type of particular capability.
Because that's going to
complicate your life.
Pick something that is
not necessarily trivial.
But don't go and pick the
most complex type of scenario
and say I'm going
to start with that.
So pick something
somewhere in the middle.
It touches upon many
aspects of the organization.
And there is value
associated with that.
And try to start applying
domain-driven design into kind
of layering down
what are the things
that I need to do as
part of the process.
And then try to understand
those type of things
that are inter-playing
together to deliver
that type of capability.
So that when I go and start
carving out or hollowing out
that particular monolith, I
understand the ramifications
of what that is.
Then we start looking
into the interfaces.
So as part of the
process, we start
looking-- if we pick one
domain, let's say it's property,
and I have different
capabilities
I want to tackle-- underwriting,
billing, and policy issuance--
as part of the process, great.
These are part of your
vocabulary that we want to do.
And there are certain
things that we use.
And then we made
the decision, we
want to be event-driven
architecture.
We start looking at
what type of events
that needs to be issued
as part of the process.
So we're trying to decouple.
We're trying to put flexible
infrastructures in place
so that these systems
can inter-communicate
as part of the process.
So as part of this,
you start high level
defining the interfaces,
identifying the microservices.
And identification
of microservices
can be another thing that
you may want to consider.
We'll talk about
it towards the end.
But at a high level,
you start doing that.
And as part of
doing that, you also
start identifying what type of
synchronous, asynchronous type
of activities that would
need to go with those.
You may want to look at the
velocity of data changes.
You may want to look
at how big the data is.
All of these good
things that you
need to understand about the
interface would be required.
And you need to find a way
to start documenting that
as part of the process.
And then that's the next
step, which we talk about--
we now look into the data
in more particular detail.
Now, it's not
enough I talk about
these particular attributes
and these microservices.
I now look at what is
the right structure
for this type of data.
Is that a JSON document that
needs to flow between A and B
systems?
What is that contract
starts looking at?
And then we start locking into
what that contract looks like.
And finalizing those steps.
And once you finalize
those contracts,
that's what other
people within the team--
whether it's offshore
development or whatever it is--
will need to start looking into.
And testers will start looking
into what type of testing plans
they need to create.
So that becomes part
of what you need
to start looking into
in terms of governance.
And making sure
that further changes
to certain type of
interfaces would
require some additional step.
So it's not just let's go
and scratch that field,
and put something else here
as quickly as we wanted to.
So that type of
activity would need
to be checked as
part of the process.
And then when you start
looking at your services
and selecting the
right building blocks,
there are many ways
that you can build this.
Whether you use the
technology from Google
or different providers,
each cloud provider
would give you certain
different type of capabilities.
We all know probably
Kubernetes is emerging
to be the global
universal runtime now
for all of this microservices
type of activities.
Functions as service is emerging
to be one of those things
that lots of companies
are discussing, and trying
to figure out what
they want to do.
And then there are things
related to infrastructure.
How you build your
infrastructure
as part of the process so that
when I go and deploy my code,
do I expect that
environment to be there?
Or do I expect to
have scripts that go
and build that
environment for me?
And then once I build
that environment,
that code gets deployed
as part of the process.
There are different
ways to look at that.
But these are part
of the decisions
that you have to make as
part of your organization.
Some of those decisions
may be appropriate upfront.
Some of them may become
later down the road,
as you gain maturity
and appreciate
the level of complexity that
would be required as part
of those type of activities.
And the selection of the right
framework is important as well.
Some companies may be
familiar with one framework
versus the other.
Don't force yourself
into something
just because company
x is doing it.
If you have certain
best practices
within your organization that
you're comfortable, happy with,
go ahead and use that.
And everything that
has to be selected
would need to be
rationalized for the process.
And then we start
looking at, OK, great,
I started defining those things.
Now we look more into
hollowing out the core,
and primarily using
the Strangler Pattern.
So trying to be getting things
out until at some point,
that monolith does not
have any reason to live,
and we kind of take things out.
Sometimes you may not
be able to be as lucky
and completely eliminate that
monolith for various reasons.
You may have to provide some
access around those type
of activities.
But at least you can take
that monolith and hollow out,
let's say, 70%, 80%, 90%
as part of the process--
if you're lucky get to 100%--
and then continue with that.
So that's important thing.
And then you start looking at
what type of business logic,
where would that
need to be existing.
And what type of
capabilities that we start
taking out from that monolith.
And definitely
those are services
that you have identified
later, and business logic
that would need to go and
live in those type of services
that you would need to create.
And then we look closely
at the events, right?
So we start looking at
these microservices.
They're communicating.
We're decoupling,
we're isolating.
So what is the pattern
of communication
between microservices?
And that's a decision
that you want to make.
Are you going to allow
your microservices
to talk to each other?
And that's a question that
we've seen it full cycle--
15, 20 years ago.
Everybody thought that
the criss-crossing mesh
of everything talking to each
other is not a good idea.
We created the bus.
And then when the API
gateway now with service
meshed, with microservices,
we're saying,
well, services can
talk to each other.
It's up to you, everybody
has their comfort zone.
But if you take that
path to an extreme,
understanding that
business code the logic,
if many of these services
start talking to each other,
you're creating a lot of
spaghetti code down the road.
So that's just something
that despite what
everybody says
about this pattern,
you can use it judiciously.
But don't go overboard
with allowing
these things happening.
And events would be
one way to look at it,
or isolating the communication
as well, another way.
And then you want to
look at data application
and change data capture.
So when things happen, when
certain state gets updated,
are there any type
of ramifications
on other consumers who may
be interested in that state?
How are you handling
those type of things?
Are you handling
those through events?
Or events and a
combination of CDC?
Or CDC or whatever it
is that you're doing.
So these are decisions that
you want to talk about.
And then you start looking
at the variety of the flows
that you need to have.
Whether it's sync,
async, fire and forget,
or events, truly events, right?
Those needs to be there.
Not everything will
be event-driven.
And if you mandate
that everything
will be event-driven,
you will be disappointed.
Because there will be a time
where batch or microbatch would
be required as part
of your architecture.
So you would have to
have certain provisions
within your architecture to
go figure out how are you
going to handle those.
What does that mean from
security and boundaries
perspective, whether I want
to enable scenario A or B or C
or D, right?
So these are important things
and questions to understand.
And as Norman mentioned earlier,
the user experience really
is one of these
things that would
drive many of those decisions.
Before we go into any of this
type of digital decoupling,
the objective is to create
something cool and fancy,
and it enables me to be more
innovative, agile, et cetera.
So we typically start
with a very nice idea
that we employ design thinking
as part of the process.
And we start ideating.
And we come up with a
very nice business value
that would allow me based
on that type of scenario--
if I carve out a
piece of it, that
would allow me to be a
differentiated type of offering
with speed to market against
my competitors, right?
So let those type of
decisions kind of dictate
what are the things
that you need to do,
rather than a blanket
statement saying everything
is event-driven.
Because there are tendencies
for companies or organizations
or humans that--
the herd mentality,
everybody is doing
this-- we follow without
necessarily thinking,
is that the right approach
for me or my organization
or my type of scenarios
that I want to enable
as part of the process.
And one of the important things
that you need to be aware of
is the rest of the architecture.
As you probably thinking
in your mind right now,
it's like, this is not
a trivial endeavor.
There are many moving parts when
you take an existing monolith
into a microservice [INAUDIBLE].
Things were much easier.
And if anybody says differently,
I would disagree with that.
Much easier to have one big
Java application or whatever
it is that everything
happens there,
I just do one build,
one release, et cetera.
Not necessarily a good way
to release business value,
I would give you that.
But if you were to start looking
at the microservice route
in all of these
type of moving parts
that you're introducing
as part of the mix,
you're adding a lot of
complexity to the question.
So that's something that
you have to be prepared for.
Whether that complexity
lies in CI/CD,
security team structure,
whatever it is.
The management of the services,
I used to manage one system,
now I have 20 services--
what do you do with that?
I had five error codes,
now I potentially
have 20 error codes.
All of these things you
have to be thinking about,
and what does that mean
to your organization
and your structure.
And then we get to the
proof of architecture step
that we talked about earlier.
Get these two primary
two use cases,
slice it across many
layers of the system,
see how this thing would
behave, and make sure
that you figure out how
your team later on would
be able to support
this type of model.
And there is the
next step, where
we go industrialize,
and making sure
that we get into automation
and all of these type of things
once we've mastered the basis.
And we expand only as necessary.
So that's important because
many people think you just
grow the team, add more bodies
to it, I'll be able to scale.
That doesn't work
with microservices.
Microservices require those
fully functional teams
where I want to have people
with different variety of skills
working as one unit.
And that has been
the best practice
for developing microservices.
Rather than having a team that
does A or B or C independently,
data, middleware, you name it.
So you want to make sure
that these things are
covered as part of the process.
And then there are
certain kinds of metrics
in terms of the plumbing--
how much time you
need to be spending on
plumbing versus other things.
Plumbing should be
taking more than 20%.
If you started a
project and you're
seeing that you're spending
more than 20% of your time
on lots of plumbing activities,
you're going overboard.
So make sure that you don't,
as you part of initial plan
or whatever plans that
you put, making sure
that those type of things are
covered as part of the process.
Now, Conway's law-- it's
something that was coined back
in the 1968 timeframe--
basically says
organizations tend
to create functions
or capabilities
or systems based on
their own infrastructure,
or their own communication
style org structure.
So you have websites
matching the structure
of the organization.
And that is not
necessarily good for how
you want to move forward.
You just need to be aware of
that and that particular bias
that we have as part of
building systems in the past.
And my objective
is to move from--
I was working with a company.
In their middleware division,
they had 200 people.
Just 200 people just
to do the middleware.
Another like 50 or 60
people just to do data.
Another team doing ETL.
It's a massive type
of organization,
with more than probably
like 3,000 people
in their IT division.
But that gives you an idea.
And things moved at a very
snail pace as part of that.
That will not work
with microservices.
You want to make sure that
you have nimble teams.
There are people and brain
trust within the team
to make decisions.
There has to be a
common ground somewhere.
Not everybody goes
doing their own thing.
But you would need
to make sure that you
have that common ground.
And then give the
teams the authority
and have the skills
within the team
so that they can
function as a unit that's
basically effective
and productive
at the end of the day.
So let's briefly look at GCP
view and what that means.
So at Accenture, we've
seen this problem.
We've seen it many times.
So we've built some
assets around them,
and we've built some
logical architecture along
with additional
physical components that
goes along with it.
And that's what you
would see if you were
to go and build it yourself.
You would have to go
and figure out, OK, I'm
doing some type of Event
Hub, which is primarily
the bread and butter of
these type of systems.
And then I have to have
certain level of microservices.
You have to make the decision,
is microservice would
have its own database.
Are you going to
share the databases?
Different pros and cons
of each one of them.
The school of
thought most likely--
the tables now are
separate independent, so
that you can run your
microservices completely
independent, scale
independently.
And independence also means
if I deploy that service,
I will not impact anybody else.
So these are part of the things
that you need to talk about
as you identify
microservices, as you
make these architectural
decisions about microservices.
And what is a microservice?
What level of granularity
of a microservice
that you are going to create
as part of the process.
For which particular domain,
and what are the objectives.
So these are things that we
have built some intelligence
around them.
And as part of that
exponential architecture,
we typically see the
pattern of data lake.
How many of you have
done a data lake
or trying to implement
a data lake today?
Lots of hands.
And those who did not raise
their hands, you will be.
Because that's a pattern right
now that lots of companies
are gaining a lot of business
traction value out of that.
So the analytics, the
AI, the capabilities
that you can get out of
that, they are significant.
And those leaders in
the industry know that.
And they are starting
their journeys
as part of the data lake.
So as part of this,
you'll see data lake.
AI services on top of
that can be invoked
through serverless
type of capabilities,
or whatever way you
want them to be invoked.
And then you have
the gateway on top
to isolate and govern
many of those aspects.
And then you have
your consumers up top,
driven by that user experience
that you created through design
thinking, and making sure
that I'm going to do that.
Now, if you translate that
to products and constructs,
this is how it looks like.
And by no means this
is a representative
of a slice of a company
or any type of assets.
All that this is representing
is these are options.
So you see that you have
[INAUDIBLE],, Doctor,
Kubernetes, containers, cloud
run, et cetera, listed there.
Cloud Functions as well.
Do I really need to go
and implement all of that?
The answer is no.
These are options
for you to consider.
And each one of those would take
probably a half hour discussion
to go over the details.
But I would encourage
each one of you
to look at what this
thing is all about.
And then the major question
that also needs to come into
is the Event Hub.
Are you part of GCP
going to use Pub/Sub?
And I put Kafka there
even though it's not GCP,
but it's coming to
GCP through Confluent
and potentially other things.
But Kafka is also is
one of those things
that you really can't
have that discussion
without talking about Kafka.
And then what are
your requirements?
Things related to indefinite
storage or order of messages.
Things can be done in GCP not
necessarily out of the box,
but you can create around them.
So we can do that, it
doesn't mean that we can't.
But there are companies who
would prefer certain things
to be done in a certain way.
And it would be a mess if
I don't put Kafka there
as part of the Event Hub.
And then there are
the things related
to Cloud Function,
streaming IoT Core, all
of these type of activities
that you need to do.
CDC type of
replication-- what do
you do about them as
part of the process?
So take that one, look at it.
And Apigee, obviously, as
part of the API gateway
is one of these
core components that
would give you a
lot of flexibility
as part of your architecture.
Here's another view of
how that may look like,
what additional capabilities
flushed out around Apigee
as part of the process.
So it's really something
that's not necessarily
highly different from what
I'd displayed earlier.
It's just something
that you need to do.
Firestore is one of
these newer products
that Google released last year.
And the model basically
does not dictate
whether you use database
A or B or C. You
can use multiple
databases, as you
languages as part
of your microservice
implementation.
So again, what your
requirements are,
do you use the same database
for the read write of you,
or something different.
So it's all depending
on what you want to do.
And if somebody was wondering
where is the marketing slide,
this is the one.
I promise it's only one slide.
It just basically
shows, we've been
there, done that, we have lots
of assets and we can help you.
I'm not going to
expand on it anymore.
But we've been in the
business for a long time.
We know what we talk about
when we talk about that.
So let me briefly
discuss the so what.
And I touch upon
items of the so what.
And that's really the--
if there is the message
that we need to take out,
it's really considering
the so what.
What does that mean for
my organization, right?
There are many things to take
out from this presentation,
but governance, for example--
and I had that as a little g,
actually, but somebody updated
it with a capital G--
perfectly fine.
Little g versus
capital G basically
means I don't want to be the--
sorry, this is a little
g, just for the record.
So capital G basically
means you raise
the stakes of rules,
regulations for everything
that you want to do.
Little g basically means
I have rails, guidelines,
and I empower you to do anything
you want to as long as you
stay within the rails.
Just a simple analogy
as much as that.
So that's a question
that you need
to think about as you start
creating microservices,
as you start creating
APIs, how you
want to govern them,
design time, runtime,
all of these type of things.
As you think about
them, design patterns--
there are many design patterns
that have been established.
The command query
response separation.
Reads, writes for microservices.
SAGA patterns for transactions.
Multi-phase commit
in microservices.
So if you have two-phase
commit requirements,
how can you handle that
as part of microservices.
Events, compensating events.
Things that you
need to consider.
Event sourcing--
is that something
that you would be
interested in replaying
type of things, when
state changes and you have
some discrepancy.
And I can go and repeat
all of these things
and recover the state
at a certain point.
All driven by requirements.
Don't get into the
mode of yeah, people
are doing this for everything.
And therefore, I
need to do this.
No, absolutely not.
There are lots of complexities
associated with that.
And let the
requirements drive it.
Yes, keep an eye on
future requirements,
just so we don't
introduce too much rework.
But let the requirements
drive what is that.
I talked about service
identification and reuse,
so that's another thing that
you may want to factor in.
Yes, independence is great.
But I want to make
sure that I am
at the right level
of granularity
and this is going to
be a reusable service.
If I'm creating a service
just for the sake of creating
a service that's going
to be used only once,
you would have to think about
that as part of the process.
I want to touch briefly
on the team structure.
So I talked about it as well.
But team structure is
one of these things
that many organizations
think that we can just
have a microservices team that
handles all microservices.
That is not necessarily
the right way to do it.
So you would want to
have the separation
between different teams.
You can have multiple teams
handling microservices,
and you have the brain
trust in these teams
to be kind of nimble enough.
It doesn't necessarily
mean one way is right
or the other way is wrong.
If you have a microservices
team within your organization
and that's working for
you, more power to you.
But if you are starting to
look at it from scratch,
that would be one of
the things to think
about as part of the process.
The networking security
and IAM, that's
a fundamental question
that you have to go through
with every GCP implementation.
You would have to spend a
decent amount of time, typically
six to eight weeks,
10 weeks, depending
on your complexity,
the environment,
to build the environment
in a production grade
type of fashion.
But for that POA, it doesn't
have to be that long.
I can start very
quickly, very fast,
in about a week, two weeks.
Put it in a sandbox,
and go quickly on that
while the other environment is
being built out in a production
grade type of fashion.
So do two things
in parallel that
would save you down the
road as part of the process.
So with that, I will hand it
back over to my colleague here.
NORMAN WOODARD: All right.
So give you a small
little case study,
examples of some of
the things we did
and kind of what
the results were.
I'm not going to go
into it in real detail.
But basically, rising
costs, compute time,
need to move migrate to cloud,
more channels being driven,
have more access channels for
consumers as well as partners.
So this particular
financial institution really
was trying to be
very innovative,
leapfrog ahead of where
the competition was,
but also really
enable more services
to get to their end users.
And also by end users meant
not only consumers, but also
their customer care, their
data banking, the retail store
banking, service agents.
So it was really kind of
a comprehensive program.
They were stymied by
having, again, monolithic
applications, monolithic
infrastructure, if you will.
So in other words,
legacy, very much slow,
wasn't API-driven, didn't
have reasonable assets,
everything was very difficult to
normally break out and separate
from a services perspective.
But also incorporate
that data and services
into modern digital
applications.
So overall, surprise,
surprise, right?
So their compute time went
down when they moved to cloud.
Yay.
There's lots of
good benefits here,
so I'm not trying to
minimize or belittle that.
But what I really
want to help you
focus on is while they became
more nimble in their innovation
and being able to get services
out to the market faster--
oh, by the way, that was
typically more than 50%
That's significant.
So they reduced their cycle
time for getting new services
out more than 50%.
And able to roll out multiple
services, not just one big
project.
And oh, by the way, that really
increased the revenue as well
as their market stance,
market positioning.
Because now they
were more prominent,
they would reach more
of their end users.
And it actually catapulted
them up in their standings
within their market segment.
So what else?
Well, security and fraud.
They also with the new
services, new capabilities,
they had additional benefits
of having better security, more
manageable services,
and better response
to their security penetration,
and also their security
architecture.
Downside that they
didn't anticipate,
it actually took them
a while internally
to go through their own internal
security and regulation process
to break out those monoliths.
So there were some aspects
that they didn't anticipate.
They still got business value.
They still created
that nimbleness,
they created that decoupling
layer, they used Apigee,
and they used containers.
And so they were able to
achieve those results.
But what they didn't
anticipate is, again,
looking inside the business,
and aligning business goals,
business priorities,
and business objectives
with IT capabilities
and IT priorities,
so that they were reaching
towards a common goal.
Hugely important.
So pulling this
all together, what
I talked about, what my
colleague Mamoun talked about--
when it comes to
re-architecting for cloud,
you've gotten a lot
of information today.
Hopefully, it's
very useful to you.
But really, it
comes down to, if we
were to simplify it,
three different areas.
So enabling growth and agility.
Enabling that
innovation and ability
to introduce new
capabilities, new services
through differentiated and
modular core capabilities
that you enable through
cloud-ready infrastructure.
Also, you want to address
current stability issues.
It will enable you to address
not only your current business
continuity plan, but also enable
robust infrastructure to where
you're going to be able
to continue to launch
new services without
service disruption,
and be able to compartmentalize
when you do have any service
or security impacts,
that you can
minimize the overall
proliferation
of those incidents.
And then, of course, every
IT group and every CIO
wants to hear, oh, we're
going to reduce costs too.
But again, it has to be
done in the right way.
You could end up spending
3x 4x 10x times which
needs to be done without
the proper planning.
So the proper planning
is so critical.
Little g, setting
up the process.
But with a big G emphasis
on getting it right.
Do the right planning up front.
Don't pass that up.
It is so critical to
have the right plan.
Figure out what
you need to do, how
to get and achieve the goals
you're trying to get to.
But define those
goals more concretely.
Don't just let a utopian
guidance of a high level,
I want to go API-centric--
how are you going to get there?
What's your microservices plan?
What's your support plan?
What's your design
state, your run state?
How are your data stores?
What's your service's
continuity plan going to be?
What is that infrastructure
supposed to look like?
Set that framework in place
first, define at a high level.
And then, without going
to the nth degree,
don't get into
paralysis by analysis.
But take the baby steps,
and start implementing today
what you need to, but
plan for tomorrow.
Key words, all right.
So wrapping this all
up-- digital decoupling,
some guiding principles.
Layering.
Apply layering to isolate your
systems, isolate your approach.
Implement appropriate
fragmentation.
So remove the pieces
that are going
to cause congestion, cause
conflicts in your architecture,
in your infrastructure,
in your applications.
But also in your
governance process too.
As Mamoun said,
keep it a small g.
Therefore, you're
driving adoption
of your infrastructure, your
systems, and your approach
and tool sets that you're
putting in place for API
microservices containers.
Simplify.
For those of you
engineers, I want
to keep it simple,
stupid, right?
Or otherwise.
And very important--
can't oversimplify that.
Not to play on it.
But in order to drive
adoption, enable self-service.
Enable your business to get
in and develop their own APIs.
Give them the infrastructure and
the capacity and the tool sets
and the guidance to have
design standards so you have
standardization and development.
But of course, you maintain
some visibility, securability,
and manageability
of those services.
Differentiated services.
Break them out.
And then automate
those, as well.
Automate the entire process.
Incorporate it into your CI/CD
process all the way through.
And that includes through
even your API platform.
One of the great things I love
about Apigee as a toolset from
an API perspective
for implementations--
because there's so
much that you can do--
leveraging Kubernetes
and Istio, and then
bringing it all together in
your CI/CD pipeline with Apigee
scripted out, to where
you can validate even what
your security policies are.
Hugely important, that
automation process.
It'll save time and money.
It's not a big investment
from instilling those process
and developing
those capabilities
and that automation.
So don't overlook that.
Cloud, we all know about.
Building your intelligence.
Building your intelligence--
not only monitoring performance,
but also look at how
your data is being used.
Look at how your
services are being used.
Who's requesting what?
Who are those end users?
So that you can understand
where your data and the data
requesting is actually how
that's driving your business.
A very important
point in understanding
where you need to
expand and continue
on your design patterns.
And then making everything
available in real time.
That invisibility
just continues to play
on building to
that intelligence,
leveraging your cloud, and
bringing it all together.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]